I don't think it's healthy to chase Fame
I don't think Fame is a is a and and you
know people might think that this is
hypocritical because I do have some
notoriety and people know me
um to be totally honest with you you
know I came to this business by accident
I was I was in retail and I got dared to
go up on stage and everything I've ever
been punished for expelled for gotten in
trouble for is what I seem to get paid
for I love interesting it is interesting
I love the idea of
um I love having fun and I love stand-up
comedy and I love the fact that I get to
do this like even right now sit and talk
to interesting people with my daughter
right but I find that um
as as Jacqueline pointed out earlier
famous fleeting you know as somebody who
comes from close to my generation I'm a
lot older than you but uh is you know
even the Beatles who reached a level of
notoriety and fame like that we hadn't
seen that's the biggest in my lifetime
right you know I have grandchildren she
has given me grandchildren they don't
know who the Beatles are famous fleeting
or saying it passes so people always ask
me in the business how do you want to be
remembered yeah how do you want to be
remembered being a famous entertainer to
be honest with you once I'm dead I'm not
really concerned about my career
how would you like to be remembered by
the people that I meet as a nice look
I'm wearing the shirt nice I just want
to be nice to everybody and I want
people to feel good that were around me
or interacted with me yeah that's how I
want it so listen I'm not listen what
you do I love comedy I knew Don and I
got to hang with him and I knew Rodney
Dangerfield and I got to hang with him
and I'm really good friends with Jeff
Ross this kind of Comedy is not
something is something that I like and
you should do it because you love doing
it you should do it because of my heart
you're making people it's fun to make
people laugh you shouldn't be doing it
because you want to be remembered you
shouldn't be doing it
do it because you like it from your
heart not for other reasons not but Fame
is is something that you you think being
famous will make you happy it just means
that people that you don't know will
stare at you while you're eating
that's funny that's all Fame is well
what is Fame
whether it's the truth you know it could
be a little Fame could be a little more
uncomfortable yes there are real good
perks that I do take advantage of I'd
like to call and try to get a seat at a
restaurant and and and I do take
advantage of that but the truth of the
matter is in the end and you said you
have two kids I have my kids and my you
know I just want them to love me and
respect me and you're a good guy how I'm
trying to be
[Music]